[Musique]
les gardiens de buts on leur propre
stage de football depuis 2020 l'ancien
portier de Poissy salive sous-marré
aujourd'hui entraîneur dans plusieurs
clubs les organismes sur le terrain de
bois flot pendant les vacances scolaires
l'objectif permettrait aux jeunes
occupant ce poste à part de pouvoir se
perfectionner de vite progresser je
passais par là quand j'étais gardien de
but au plus haut à mon plus jeune âge on
n'avait pas cette chance là d'abord des
autres modes gardiens et j'ai pu le voir
sur le tard que bah j'avais quelques
lacunes duo fêté que j'avais pas de
d'entraînement de gardien de but du coup
comme je suis passé par là j'avais pas
forcément de spécifices gardiens moi
maintenant mon but à moi c'est justement
de transmettre au plus jeune gardien
pour qu'il puisse avoir les incliner
nécessaire pour justement bah c'est pas
mieux à ce poste là au programme de la
semaine de stage travail de la technique
de gardien de but de la prise de balle
au plongeon en passant par les sorties
aériennes et le jeu au pied 5 éducateurs
proposent différents ateliers au 25
gardiens participants des catégories U10
à U16 le tout sous l'oeil avisé de
salive sous-marin qui est supervise les
entraînements c'est quoi un bon gardien
pour toi aujourd'hui quelle qualité il
doit avoir bah il doit être très fort
mentalement
très très fort mentalement et il doit
surtout maintenant maintenant avec
l'évolution du football avoir un très
bon sens de jeu et surtout bah le reste
va être très bon sur sa ligne quoi c'est
vraiment un poste à part et donc c'est
pour ça ça demande beaucoup d'exigences
mentale qu'est-ce qui me plaît j'aime
bien faire des sorties ça ça me plaît
j'aime bien ce méchant parce que j'adore
être méchant j'aime bien les marques des
gants j'aime bien tout en fait tout ce
qui est gardien j'aime bien c'est bien
de gardien puisque bah ça sauve son
équipe parce que quand la balle elle est
là avec tes face à face avec l'attaquant
bah il y a plus que toi et du coup bah
tu peux sauver ton équipe et rester bah
si tu si tu arrêtes le but bah c'est toi
la sauce du match quoi
les gardiens viennent des meilleurs
clubs de la région et de France et sont
souvent des habitués des stages j'aime
bien ces stages ils sont bien parce
qu'il y a plusieurs ateliers c'est pas
tout le temps les mêmes thèmes et bah
les éducateurs ils ont pas les mêmes
méthodes d'apprendre le premier rang que
j'ai commencé à faire du stage salive du
coup qui m'a qui a commencé à
m'entraîner je les prises de balle je
faisais que les relâcher les ballons je
plongeais des fois avec les pieds je
tape les et bah au fil des années j'ai
commencé à plonger avec les mains il m'a
appris des bonnes choses il m'a appris
les réflexes il m'a appris les sortir
rien parce qu'avant je faisais que
mettre les points maintenant j'arrive à
la garder franchement je suis content
que mon papa m'a inscrit merci papa
comptait 150 € avec une paire de gants
fournis prochain rendez-vous pendant les
vacances d'hiver de Pâques et début
juillet les places sont limitées à 20 ou
25 gardiens